[Musique] de
travers était une piscine attrapée à la loterie comme
à bord d'un homme non magique Je pense que nous
devrions y aller oui ceci pour vous faire
bien paraître j'ai plus de choses à développer tard
pourquoi pourquoi mais je pense que nous restons tous
ensemble en tant qu'Europe la  comment vous le savez
pour avoir vu des nouvelles nous près de Tucson
contre
qui est-ce qui a appelé pourquoi pourquoi
[Musique]
allons-y selfie augmenté bon prélèvement j'ai
senti que nous devrions définitivement entrer pour l'
avenir je suis de manière équivalente à des fins futures
pour vivre à peu près comme pour
si je comprends bien en tant
qu'homme britannique dans la rue la position
est acceptable pour le général de Gaulle et
les autres membres le mariage et
les délires de Sebastiaan calment un passager vers
une position économie Kate accepte un bleu
polonais du général de Gaulle une pensée de Polly
est à mon avis extrêmement  douteux pendant de
nombreuses années à venir ne le maudissez pas
bien sûr je ne donne pas de pourboire ou ne fais pas plus qu'un
placage c'est à certains égards oui à d'autres
égards quand il s'agit d'une question
de prix des aliments non ce rapport en vente
un  bout de secouer sur ça
Oh puskás nombreux avant Caulfield est
votre baume à lèvres de rechange président de Gaulle
mais nouveau permis un permis émettre leur propre
bande-annonce Masha vient c'est bien nous
Joseph un livre si je suis sur votre chemin alors
aujourd'hui prune personnellement moi-même j'allais
faire autant de bien là-dedans oui une
perspective d'émotion terrible pourrait
être honnête mais si le gouvernement dit que
c'est vous savez bien alors ça doit être
vrai
armoire antique
difficulté occidentale voir Rihanna le castillo de
la moune avec un égal à la livre
sterling qui arpente le Commonwealth
contre le code aqua pourquoi pourquoi la simple
raison pour laquelle on ne nous donne pas assez de détails
sur les avantages et ce que nous allons
obtenir contre nous sommes  plus contre les
étudiants en droit et les personnes utilisent vos étudiants du
tout les shirley d'aujourd'hui, je ne désavoue pas vraiment
- c'est un Covino pour lequel je suis pour oh
est-ce que c'est bien la piscine et je pense  que cela
nous donnera un marché beaucoup plus grand pour
nos produits et je suis en fait ce qui pourrait
être un légume sans gousse nous et je pense que
cela nous donnera l'opportunité d'
étendre notre industrie et sans cela de
cette façon pour le faire nous shan'  t Sénat
un autre cas vous êtes les ils ne le font pas ou
meurent Gandhi le 803 et cela nous rejoignons
le Marché commun J'ai peur que nous devions prendre du
retard dans la course car c'est un
massacre ouvert peut-être qu'un dormeur pourrait être sur un
parcours
[La musique]